hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy rules are you
must use the food given you can only add
to the food you can buy whatever
ingredients you wish let's see what we
are making fancy today drum loads
flaming hot cheetos
i've had this before so you like them
i've had it i didn't say i like them
it's a little bit overpowering for my
palette i don't admire the color that
much because it is a little bit
artificial
if you like spicy food i can see it's
addictive it's a nice crunch and there
is like subtle sweetness flavor is very
strong so i think it will be good
ingredients for savory food i want to
make something with a lot of different
varieties but still want to take
advantage of flaming hot flavor
oh
so i got some great ideas and i'm
excited to
make it fancy
all right here is what i got sour cream
chicken thighs butter buttermilk micro
greens honey eggs fossils from the
pantry i got flour oil paprika cayenne
garlic powder onion powder sugar brown
sugar baking soda baking powder black
pepper and mustard powder okay let's get
started
make it fancy
first a cup of honey i made a how honey
is made video so basically honey is
beads vomit that's what i learned but
it's very fascinating now i'm not too
afraid of beads so now i know how to
avoid being stung one cup of cheetos
i'm going to use more cheetos later so
i'm going to just skip this around make
sure cheetos is submerged with honey
each piece has a different shape it's
very unique we are heating up honey so
honey infuse the cheetos flavor and
making the hot cheetos honey gentle
simmer for like a couple minutes and a
ton of the heat set aside for 15 to 20
minutes and we are moving on to next
step grind some hot cheetos so you want
to ground it until very fine
powder you use quarter cup of cheetos
powder one teaspoon of cayenne kind is
very spicy
oh i think i inhaled it so if you don't
like too spicy you can just
oh okay
you can just use cheetos powder and skip
cayenne two tablespoons of paprika one
tablespoon of mustard powder one
tablespoon of onion powder one
tablespoon of garlic powder and one
tablespoon of black pepper mix
why spicy food and whole foods
associated with health you know if you
buy hot sauce there's usually devil or
like skull so this is like a hell
health spice spice mix it's done move on
the next step i have boiling skin on
chicken tights and pot dry just remove
the moisture from chicken place the
chicken in a bowl and season with salt
six tablespoons of this spice mix
marinate the chicken so i want to
marinate at least two hours to overnight
and i'm going to cover with plastic and
rest in the refrigerator the cheetos is
steeping
about 15 minutes and i'm going to strain
looks super red
it's really good it's like spicy honey
we are going to use it later we're gonna
set this aside half cup of canola oil
two tablespoons of the spice mix i made
earlier two teaspoon of brown sugar so
you just want it to heat up and make
sure the brown sugar is completely
melted i think cheetos
it's vertical in a way when you're
making something spicy i don't think you
can use for everything but um you can
substitute some like spice mix with
grounded cheetos brown sugar is melted
and i'm going to set this aside moving
on to next step combine dry ingredients
one and a half cup of flour 3 4 cup of
ground cheetos 2 tbsp of sugar 1 and
half teaspoon of baking powder half
teaspoon of baking soda i'm shifting
because i can get rid of those big
chunks of cheetos half teaspoon of salt
kosher soda is a little bit big grain so
when you shift it sometimes it doesn't
go through so i don't usually shift salt
set this aside and i'm going to make my
wet ingredients half cup of sour cream
one and a half cup of buttermilk butter
cream is a little bit tangy it's like
sour separate four eggs we are whisking
egg white later so make sure there is no
egg yolk trace in a egg white bowl and
make sure the bowl is clean four
tablespoons of melted butter
mix well
with whisk set this aside combine my wet
ingredients to dry ingredients whip my
egg whites whisk the egg whites until
hard peak and switch to spatula and fold
in the egg whites you don't want to use
whisk because you don't want to kill all
the bubbles you create it with making
meringue really has there ever been a
product that you tried at the start of
the makeup fancy episode that you now
have regularly
okay butter it's good to go and we're
gonna cook it so i'm using nonstick
waffle maker scoop my butter for half
cup i like brunch food in general i like
pancakes french toast waffle i've never
tried hot waffle i hope it's gonna be
good
looks good
one down whenever you go to hotel with
continental breakfast day it's like
waffle station it's always a mess butter
is everywhere there's a long way
i'm gonna go one more right this one is
ready flaming hot cheetos waffle looks
good i'm going to cook rest of the
butter and moving on to the next step so
we have this chicken from the fridge
marinating about two hours two cup of
buttermilk two tablespoons of parcels
that'll take a long time lightly mix
i'm going to dredge in the flour dipping
in the buttermilk mixture and dredging
the flour again so you can have kind of
crispy
crust so we are frying at 325 fahrenheit
about 10 to 12 minutes you don't want to
over crowd your pot so i'm frying two at
the time it's important to have
thermometer because if you are frying
way too high heat
outside it's only cooking and inside
it's not cooked it's been 10 to 12
minutes i'm going to check the inner
temperature
has to be 165
so it's ready if your chicken is getting
darker in oil and in a temperature it's
not reaching 165 just finish in oven the
crust looks very crispy and i'm going to
brush the oil i made earlier and you
want to make sure the oil is hot so it
doesn't cool down the chicken the reason
i'm using oil-based sauce so it doesn't
make chicken crust soggy if you make the
sauce with like water-based it's gonna
make it soggy finish rest of the chicken
and moving on to the next step so all
the ingredients are ready and i'm going
to plate brush melted butter on the
waffle
i want to finish with a little bit spice
i made the micro green just like nice
little salad
and we are done
[Music]
flaming hot chicken and waffle it's very
fancy
andrew adam welcome back to another make
you fancy episode fried chicken and
waffle
is it um i want to guess okay
is it
strawberry milk syrup
no flaming hot cheetos
oh there is a dust here
there there is like a uh
spicy dust i'm gonna use my hands out i
can see that
it's good right those are good yeah
it's sweet
and a little spicy yeah
does it taste like a strawberry milk it
does not taste like strawberry milk no i
i can taste the cheeto do you remember
you made me a flaming hot cheetos
breeder for eating your feed i do yeah
oh yeah
you liked it but you were mad that you
liked it yes
oh did you make a batter from the
cheetos yeah so i mean what i'm shocked
at how good this is
make it fancy
so we have a special guest today
jane harris she is a la times senior
food writer and official
fried chicken queen it looks spicy it's
very red and orange and i feel like it's
going to make my head tingle because of
how red it is i want to it reminds me of
flamin hot cheetos i would love to try
it yeah okay great
that's delicious fried chicken yes
that tastes like hot cheetos
i will bow down to your queen
this is awesome this is very good i can
keep eating it right yes okay great
this chicken is structurally sound it's
super moist in the middle but then the
out you have this like really great
craggly crispy skin that's like sticks
with the chicken it doesn't like
separate from the skin the honey is
great because it's i mean that's what i
normally eat well i normally honey and
hot sauce with my chicken so you did it
for me with cheetos
do you like plain hot cheetos i love my
mochi okay if anyone says they don't
they're lying okay
make it fuzzy
[Music]